hey how you doing today folks in today's
video I wanted to discuss the plot
leaked a little bit or at least review a
part of the plot leaked because I've
referenced it in several of my videos
and I don't want people to get the wrong
impression I don't want people to think
that I believe the entire leak is true
so I actually want to review each one of
the episodes and discuss and go over
what I think is true and what I think's
false and some of the things that I hope
does not happen some of the things I
actually do want to see happen next
season so I'm going to go over the first
episode and discuss it section by
section and tell you guys what sounds
true and to be honest with you the first
episodes seems pretty plausible because
the show has set itself up and put
itself in position for these things to
happen so a lot of it does seem
reasonable but there are definitely some
things in this leak that I think is just
completely made-up and I really don't
see happening so let's begin with the
first episode it says the White Walkers
are marching south on the wall now that
seems pretty obvious the White Walkers
at some point have to get through this
wall to push the story forward the whole
series has been building up towards this
big battle with basically mankind
fighting the others and now that there's
really nothing left up north for them to
do now that Craster's dead there's no
babies for them to take and turn into
White Walkers defends the wildlings
pretty much all the people up there have
been killed off or brought south so
there's no one up there for them to turn
into White's
they really have no purpose to be up
there still so they definitely have to
get south to the wall and get through it
to have this big war start so I
definitely see that happening at some
point I don't know about episode 1 but
it's definitely going to happen next
season and it says bran crosses the wall
back into Westeros and meets what the
Lord said the new Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch and if I mispronounce his
name I apologize and that also seems
pretty reasonable
we know branimir is right outside the
wall at the weirwood tree and at some
point he has to get back south to get
safe with just him and mirror out there
he really has no protection against the
white
Walker's which we know are going to be
approaching pretty fast considering he
has that mark on his arm the night's
king knows where he's at at all times
and brand knows that after what happened
at the three-eyed Ravens cave he should
be well aware of what's actually going
on but he may be smart enough to realize
that that mark on his arm could dispel
the magic in the wall so he could
potentially send mirror to get help at
Castle black and hopefully get John up
there to protect him as he's outside the
wall that way he doesn't bring it down
but it's hard to say he may not have
time to sit up there and wait and he may
just pass through it regardless of what
might happen so that's still to be seen
to be determined and it also says Sansa
and John have an argument about what to
do with the northern houses who betrayed
them by fighting with the Bolton's sands
and Lyanna Mormont want to give their
lands to loyal supporters but John
refuses to hold the Karstark a number
children responsible John does it his
way and basically tells the others to
deal with it because he's not going to
rule the north the way it's always been
that's pretty reasonable we know John
has always kind of done things his own
way and there's no reason for him to
start changing now
I definitely think he's going to stay
true to himself and want to unite
everybody still he doesn't want to kill
people you know for no real reason
especially kids that may not have had
anything to do with their parents
opposing him he's probably going to want
to give these kids a chance to reclaim
their houses and become loyal to John
and fight in a war but I could also see
Sansa having a problem with that because
they are the children of those who
oppose John so I could see it actually
going both ways why she'd have a problem
with it and why John would just want to
you know let them keep their lands so I
give that about a 50/50 chance of
happening and we've seen two new kids on
set well at least a girl she could be
passed off as a teenager she's probably
in her 20s but we see a little boy as
well so those two new actors that her
film in season seven could potentially
be the Karstark a number children so I
wouldn't doubt CNM filmer seemed a scene
similar to what they're saying here in
this league and says at the end of the
episode Daenerys and company arrive at
Dragonstone she goes into the old
room with the table map of Westeros and
turns to Tyrion and says shall we begin
now that's also pretty plausible we
definitely know Daenerys and company is
going to arrive at Dragonstone or King's
Landing
very soon her entire story has been her
wanting to get to Westeros in the King's
Landing to fight for the Iron Throne
which she believes is hers which she
believes she has every right to be
sitting on and at the end of season six
we saw her and her supporters and her
fleet and her army head towards Westeros
so we definitely knows he's going to get
there very soon episode one I'm not
really sure because the report came out
back in September or maybe even before
that way before the ploy League came out
that Daenerys was going to get into a
battle at sea against your on and that's
when he was going to capture Yara and
kill one of the sand snakes so if that
happens I'm not sure if they're going to
have enough time to show her arrived at
Dragonstone as well because they're
going to need the first episode next
year to set up all the main characters
and let you know in which direction our
story is going to go so I don't know if
they'd have time to show her flight
you're on and arrive at Dragonstone at
the same time unless the battle took
place very close to Dragonstone or if it
was a very quick battle we know Euron's
building a thousand ships so I'm not
sure if he had all those made in time to
get out there and fight Daenerys before
she arrives at Dragonstone but he could
possibly send out a small fleet to try
and flank her or attack the rear to just
take out some of her forces or at least
try to kill or capture Theon and Yara so
I could definitely see that taking place
and we know she's definitely going to
Rive at Dragonstone at some point in
season seven there's already been a
bunch of photos that have came out that
have shown her and her forces arrived on
a beach that appears to be Dragonstone
just by the looks at some of the set
pieces with the sharp and razor looking
rocks that's pretty much what
Dragonstone is so I'm pretty confident
that's where she's at in those photos so
most of the plot leaked for episode 1
seems pretty legit
the stories kind of set up for all these
things to take place so I could
definitely see all this happening but
some of the other episodes there are
some things that I definitely don't
think could take place but in this video
I just wanted to go over the first
episode and discuss it I want to get
some feedback from you guys because I
know some of you think some of the plot
leaked is true or some of it sounds like
it's pretty plausible and I'm wondering
if what's in this episode is some of
that stuff so comment below tell me what
you think about this episode does this
seem plausible to you or does this seem
completely made-up as well thanks for
listening guys and I'll see you tomorrow
bye